schön dass Sie dabei sind meine Damen
und Herren heutzutage ist es nicht
selbstverständlich dass man überhaupt
noch Lust hat die Kiste anzumachen aber
es gibt auch einzelne Momente die Mut
machen zum Beispiel die tolle Rede des
ukrainischen Präsidenten selensky
gestern im Bundestag stehende Ovation
Richtung hier und das klare Signal wir
stehen an eurer Seite und an eurer
Rückseite kaufen wir weiter Öl und Gas
aus Russland aber unter Protest direkt
danach keine ukraine-debatte sondern
Tagesordnung inklusive Geburtstagsgrüße
wie heißt nochmal das Gegenteil von
Sternstunde keine Ahnung selensky
beeindruckt die Parlamente der freien
Welt und Wladimir Putin ist inzwischen
völlig isoliert ja der sitzt nur noch
wütend im Kreml und feuert den ganzen
Tag Generäle wobei klar isoliert war ja
schon vor dem Einmarsch in die Ukraine
wie diese Bilder beweisen
[Musik]
irgendjemand nein schade Putins Nerven
liegen blank gerade hat er wieder
Schweden und Finnland mit militärischen
Konsequenzen gedroht falls Sie doch mal
eines Tages in die NATO wollen die
Schweden stocken jetzt ihren
Verteidigungsetat um 4 Milliarden auf
die Schweden alte Regel leg dich nicht
mit den Erfindern von Köttbullar an der
russische Außenminister spricht zwar von
Fortschritten in den Verhandlungen mit
der Ukraine aber kann man dem oder
seinen Boss noch irgendwas glauben die
Abstände zwischen Putins Wutanfällen
werden jedenfalls immer kürzer ist so
heute hat er eine propaganda-rede in
einem Sportstadion gehalten musste als
Diktator mindestens einmal im Leben
gemacht haben
verwestlichte Oligarchen und
putin-krediger müssen sich dabei im
Staatsfernsehen so was hier anhören
irgendwo in rot die Menschen in Russland
werden fähig sein die wahren Patrioten
von Abschaum und Verrätern zu
unterscheiden sie werden sie einfach
ausspucken wie ein Insekt das ihn
versehentlich in den Mund geflogen ist
ausspucken auf den Bürgersteig
hui da hat sich wohl ein bisschen was
aufgestaut bei Väterchen Frust wie er
liegt wahrscheinlich an der
militärischen vollblamage die ja gerade
in der Ukraine erleidet angeblich sagen
amerikanische Geheimdienste bittet er
schon China um Hilfe konkret um
chinesische Fertiggerichte für seine
Soldaten ist so eine wunderbare
Vorstellung wenn so ein russischer
Soldat nach dem Essen sein Glückskeks
aufmacht warte mal wer lächelt statt zu
toben ist immer der Stärkere
denk mal drüber nach Wladimir tut dann
natürlich nicht stattdessen befiehlt er
Terrorangriffe um die ukrainische
Bevölkerung zu demoralisieren und
drangsaliert seine eigene
Linie
landesweit soll nach Angaben von
Bürgerrechtlern gestern mehr als 900
Demonstranten festgenommen worden sein
selbst wenn Sie nur ein weißes Blatt
hoch gehalten haben ja liebe Querdenker
sie sahen eine richtige Diktatur bei uns
kann man mit Lauterbach als Hitler
demonstrieren unter Putin nicht mal mit
einem leeren Plakat schon gar nicht mit
dem was die inzwischen weltberühmte
Redakteurin Marina auf sanikowa live ins
Russische tv-gehalten hat stoppt den
Krieg hier werdet ihr belogen das ist
unfassbar mutig in einem ersten Urteil
hat man sie gerade zu einer Geldstrafe
von 30.000 Rubel verurteilt es wäre
entstand jetzt ungefähr zwölf Euro 40
jetzt nur noch zehn Moment neun egal ja
leider droht ja auch noch Gefängnis wer
macht sonst Mut in diesen Tagen zum
Beispiel die drei Regierungschefs von
Polen Tschechien und Slowenien die
Präsident selensky in Kiew besucht haben
also in der belagerten Hauptstadt eines
Landes im Krieg und jetzt kommt der
eigentliche Hammer die sind da mit dem
Zug hingefahren
verstehen sie in der Ukraine fahren noch
Züge
ich will jetzt keinen angucken aber es
gibt Unternehmen die schon den Betrieb
einstellen wenn mal drei Blätter auf die
Schienen fallen
andererseits müssen wir sagen hilft die
Deutsche Bahn natürlich ukrainische
Flüchtlinge nach Deutschland zu bringen
allein in Berlin treffen jeden Tag rund
10.000 Menschen ein und was freiwillige
Helfern da leisten beschämt einfach alle
die seit 2015 versuchen aus Gutmensch
ein Schimpfwort zu machen ehrenamtliche
top
deutsche Behörden bemüht jeden Morgen
Haren hier ukrainische Flüchtlinge die
bereits eine Unterkunft haben in der
Kälte aus um sich registrieren zu lassen
Unverständnis warum das nicht
elektronisch geht Ukraine ist ein
it-land bei uns ist schon über Jahren
elektronische ID-Karte bekannt ja aber
bei uns ist vorne im Amt so ein Kasten
da zieht man sich eine Nummer raus und
das ist fast genauso gut außerdem hat
Innenministerin Nancy Faeser gerade eine
App in Auftrag gegeben die heißt Germany
for you Crain der erfahren die Ukraine
alles was man über das Leben in
Deutschland wissen muss hier ein
exklusiver sneak peak zum Beispiel dass
wir in Deutschland gerne mit Formularen
aus Papier Arbeiten die mit einem
sogenannten Stift ausgefüllt werden zur
Not können Sie in Deutschland mit Karte
zahlen Landesbrauch ist aber eher
Bargeld am besten passen dann ganz viele
Infos über deutsche Mülltrennung da sind
wir wahnsinnig stolz drauf hier fährt
man seitenweise alles Wissenswerte über
die blaue Tonne die gelbe die Biotonne
wo Batterien reinkommen wo Glühbirnen
bis hin zum schönsten deutschen Wort
überhaupt Wertstoffhof plus ein kurzes
Unterkapitel über Spaß haben in
Deutschland versuchen Sie bitte nicht es
zu verstehen wir verstehen es selber
nicht aber wie gesagt die
unbürokratische Hilfe durch freiwillige
ist schon extrem beeindruckend extrem
gut auf eine Hilfsaktion hätte man im
Nachhinein verzichten können ein Rentner
aus Hannover ein entlaufener Rentner hat
wohl versucht eigene
Friedensverhandlungen mit Putin in
Moskau zu führen und das war
offensichtlich völlige Zeitverschwendung
also mal abgesehen von den Fotos die
unterwegs auf dieser Reise entstanden
sind denn mindestens eins davon schreibt
regelrecht Kunstgeschichte meint Dietmar
Wischmeyer
[Musik]
die betende am Fenster ein verstörendes
Bild elektrisiert die Welt bei der
wechselnden Madonna handelt es sich um
soyon Schröder Kim den Gedanken bei
ihrem Gatten in der kreml-schanze Wald
Gerd lasst das hat er sie noch vor der
Abreise gewarnt der Wladi hat genug um
die Ohren mit seiner sonderzerstörung
des brudervolks die du ihm nicht auch
noch auf die Nüsse doch vergebens ein
Schröder in seinem Lauf halten weder
Scholz noch Kevins auf ach Kimmy hat er
geantwortet der Lupen rein und ich haben
schon zusammen gesoffen dass du noch bei
Samsung die platinengebon hat
doch eins hatte der alte veganist seine
Angetrauten bis er verschwiegen der
Patriarch von Moskau hatte ihn und
Vladimir atomovic vor Jahren heimlich
getraut und diesen Männerbund konnte
nichts und niemand trennen
gertsentschluss stand fest er würde
versuchen seinen Blutsbruder die Ukraine
Flausen auszureden Schröder kim hat
ihren Gerd vom Hotel noch zur Metro
begleitet und dann lange nichts mehr von
ihm gehört sie bangte um großväterchen
selbst in Hannover hat er sich schon
etliche Male verlaufen und dann auweia
in Moskau mit all den Fremden Buchstaben
immerhin war die Reise ein voller Erfolg
Wladimir Demolierung würde bei seinem
Vorstoß nach Westen vor Schröders Konto
halt machen
sie hatten sich beim Abschied in den
Armen gelegen alles war so eng wie immer
zwischen die beiden passte keine noch so
kleine Ukraine
endlich wieder zu Hause dort heizt
Gastraum den Wok und Nord Stream füllt
die Rotweingläser nach wer brauchte dann
auch treulose Mitarbeiter und ein
vergibt es Parteibuch
schröder-kim hat er den
karnickelzüchtern von der SPD über
Instagram schon mal eine Warnung
zukommen lassen bevor ihr den Gerd aus
der SPD rauswerft schmeißt er euch alle
raus und bleibt alleine drin basta
was wollten die denn noch alles
schließlich hat er sogar auf die
Ehrenbürger würde von Hannover
verzichtet das bedeutet nicht mehr
günstig in der rathauskantine Essen und
umsonst Straßenbahn fahren da könnte er
jetzt bei aller Liebe nicht auch noch
auf die 800.000 aufsichtsratsmoneten
verzichten man lebt schließlich nur
einmal
geblieben von Schröders Reise ist die
brütende Ikone am Fenster im Hintergrund
die Basilius Kathedrale in Abendstimmung
gehört wer das Foto geschossen hat
wissen wir immer noch nicht nur eins
wissen wir Gerd Schröder war es nicht so
spät am Tage wäre es bei ihm verwackelt
[Musik]
Dietmar Wischmeyer so Hefte raus
Stillarbeit wie schafft es Deutschland
aus der Abhängigkeit von Putins Gas und
Öl ich weiß es keins mehr kaufen nein
das wäre zu einfach oder um ein
berühmtes trainerwort abzuwandeln
entscheidend ist eine zapzone natürlich
Diesel 2 Euro 30 übrigens obwohl der
Ölpreis an der Börse zuletzt
runtergegangen ist so dass man vermuten
könnte dass hier Preisabsprachen der
Mineralölkonzerne im Spiel sind aber hey
da steckst du nicht drin wer beruflich
viel fahren muss ist jedenfalls schwer
gekniffen und zurecht sauer das geht ja
nicht so weit ich wein wenn das denn
noch so weit in der Kostenarten normal
so große Schweinerei dass man das gewagt
hat über eine Mark zu gehen
ja diese Interviews haben wir aus
technischen Gründen vor 50 Jahren
aufgezeichnetem und nicht vergessen eine
Mark war in den 70ern tierisch viel Geld
ne hat man damals noch zehn Bitcoins zu
bekommen der Verband der Spediteure
spricht von der größten Krise seit dem
Zweiten Weltkrieg und warnt vor leeren
Supermarktregal doch Rettung naht meine
Damen und Herren denn Christian Lindner
hat seine Spendierhosen aus der
Reinigung geholt wir werden jetzt wenn
es nach mir geht einmal einen Vorschlag
machen für einen fixen
krisenrabatt Kraftstoffe der könnte 30
oder 40 Cent betragen cool Christian
Lindner in der rapperszene auch bekannt
als 40 Cent verkündet den Tankrabatt bei
jedem Liter gehen dann vielleicht bald
40 Cent auf seinem Deckel so ein netter
Mann aber ist ihnen überhaupt richtig
klar was sie gerade gehört haben meine
Damen und Herren die FDP möchte den
Preis für ein Produkt nicht mehr dem
freien Markt überlassen
[Musik]
ja sie sehen mich erstaunt und das ist
der Unterschied zur mietpreisbremse die
war wir erinnern uns für die FDP blanker
Kommunismus aber Autofahrern muss man
natürlich unbürokratisch helfen ist ja
klar 40 Cent das würde mehr als zwei
Milliarden kosten und zwar jeden Monat
ist wo genau holen wir das Geld jetzt
wieder her ich übersetze das noch einmal
wir leihen uns Geld
aus der Zukunft
neben der Schuldenbremse ach so das Geld
kommt aus der Zukunft genial wenn du
zahlst das Freundchen findest du nicht
gut ja dann musst du dich beschweren
Babys man könnte übrigens gezielt
Geringverdiener Speditionen und
Fernpendler entlasten statt mit der
Gießkanne zu arbeiten Lindner holt Geld
aus der Zukunft das später alle
zurückzahlen auch Leute die mit dem
Fahrrad zur Arbeit fahren er hält pro
forma an der Schuldenbremse ab nächstem
Jahr fest arbeitet aber mit
ergänzungshaushalten und Sondervermögen
das ist echt wie früher bei neuen live
wissen Sie noch unser Chrissi sucht
andere Worte für Schulden los Leute
jetzt anrufen der Hot Button sucht wie
könnte man Schulden schöner nennen
dorniges Guthaben sehr gut oder auch
geheimes unsichtbares Ninja Budget
wunderbar wie wäre es mit Magic Mystery
money und natürlich überraschend
aufgetauchte Sofa ritzengeld alles
besser als Schulden ja meine keine Frage
PR-technisch war Lindners Idee ein
absoluter Volltreffer Tankrabatt das
versteht jeder im Gegensatz zu
energiegeld bei den Grünen es ist viel
zu komplex viel zu kopfig und sind wir
mal ehrlich vom Thema Klima will ja
gerade eh keiner was hören also trotz
co2-rekord in 2021 das machen wir alles
später immer eine Krise nach der anderen
das müssen die wütenden Kinder auch mal
einsehen was man übrigens sofort machen
könnte wären autofreie Sonntag also die
Heldengeschichte der Boomer Generation
autofreie Sonntage wäre da eine Maßnahme
die glaube ich auch sogar vielen
Menschen Spaß bringen würde die
Vorstellung mal auf Autobahnen wandern
gehen oder Rad zu fahren oder auf den
Straßen zu spielen nur der sich zu
sonnen ja klar einfach mal die Seele
baumeln lassen am Kreuz Dortmund Unna
why not und zum Mittagessen grillt man
sich einen überfahrenen Igel vom Vortag
autofreier Sonntag warum denn nicht man
muss es den meckerköpfen nur schmackhaft
verkaufen
chill Sunday denn an normalen Sonntagen
ist es ja so man fährt nach dem
Mittagessen zum Spazieren gehen in
irgendeinen bekackten Wald und die
Plagen hassen einen dafür oder man Kart
den Sohn zum Fußball obwohl alle wissen
dass er null Talent hat eine Stunde im
Auto um dann bei Oma Hilde Tiefkühl
Bienenstich zu fressen das verstopft die
Autobahn und die Arterien beim chill
Sunday formulieren autofreier Sonntag
dagegen kann ich mir schon zum Frühstück
den ersten Rotwein reinlöten weil ich ja
nicht mehr fahren muss nix autofreier
Sonntag es ist schlicht der beste
Sonntag aller Zeiten
ein träumchen leider hat der Jil Sunday
einen kleinen Schönheitsfehler selbst
wenn jeder zweite Sonntag autofrei wäre
spart das nur 1,4% der deutschen
Ölimporte mehr berechte das schon ein
Tempolimit 100 auf der Autobahn gleich
8% weniger Öl aus Russland Vorschlag
gebt doch endlich das Hand frei
legalisiert Cannabis dann akzeptieren
die Bürger auch das Tempolimit natürlich
denn bekifft am Steuer denkt man ja dass
man super schnell fährt
Höchstgeschwindigkeit aber das täuscht
außerdem kann natürlich jeder von uns im
Alltag Energie sparen in allen möglichen
Situationen früher hatte man da nie
richtig Bock drauf aber jetzt wo es
Putin trifft auf allen Kanälen nur noch
Spartipps für den energiekrieg nur die
Räume beheizen die man tagsüber auch
wirklich nutzt Kochen mit Deckel spart
rund 30 Prozent vielleicht noch ein
Pullover anziehen Tür zu machen hilft
Rollläden runter und Vorhänge schließen
versuchen nicht besonders lang zu
duschen ich möchte in einer Welt leben
in der ich aus der Toilette trinken kann
ohne Ausschlag zu bekommen
ja mach doch ist Prinzip ist klar
geworden der einzelne soll weniger
heizen ist nie verkehrt viele ärmere
Familien machen das allerdings schon
seit Jahren nur nicht wegen Putin
sondern wegen kein Geld so oder so
Deutschland muss tatsächlich
unabhängiger werden übrigens auch bei
bestimmten Lebensmitteln in deutschen
Supermärkten geht wohl schon wieder das
Hamstern los
warum meine es gibt Weltregionen um die
muss man sich Sorgen machen Nordafrika
einige arabische Staaten wo bald
wirklich Hunger droht andererseits haben
wir in Deutschland natürlich auch
Probleme Sonnenblumenöl wird knapp
breaking news die Ölkrise ist zurück
also die sonnenblumenöl-krise
und wir schalten direkt mal live in
einen Supermarkt in Wuppertal Elberfeld
zu Carolin Kebekus Carolin wideramatisch
ist die Sonnenblumenöl Lage gar nichts
ist dramatisch Oliver es ist einfach nur
albern immer derselbe Reflex die doofen
sehen im Fernsehen ständig Berichte über
knappes Öl und dann reden sie in den
Supermarkt kaufen Öl für die nächsten 10
Jahre und wundern sich das Öl knapp ist
hier sehe ich übrigens auch uns in der
Verantwortung wir Medien müssen mit der
Sonnenblumenöl Berichterstattung
aufhören die Leute werden zu Tieren Mann
kauf doch einfach irgendein anderes
scheißöl ja Vorsicht Frau Kollegin
sonnenblumenöl ist schon ziemlich
perfekt zum frittieren und wie soll man
bitte sein Essen zubereiten wenn man es
nicht mehr Frittieren kann
jetzt mal ernsthaft das arme
supermarktpersonal hat doch in den
letzten zwei Jahren weiß Gott genug
durchgemacht erst Corona und jetzt das
hier
Speiseöle werden zum Teil bereits
rationiert Kunden dürfen somit in
einigen Discountern und Supermärkten nur
noch eine bestimmte Menge kaufen also es
ist jeder zweite Kunde kommt morgens
rein und fragte mal nach haben sie
Sonnenblumenöl haben sie Rapsöl haben
sie Sonnenblumen es geht wirklich früh
morgens um 7 Uhr los
klar was stimmt die Ukraine ist der
weltweit größte Erzeuger von Sonnenblume
haben Sie vielleicht nein
das eigentliche Thema ist nicht das
blöde Öl sondern unsere Landwirtschaft
wir müssen bei Dünger und Tierfutter
endlich wieder autarker werden und da
gibt es zwei Möglichkeiten manche
Experten sagen um auf kleinere Fläche
mehr Ertrag zu erzielen brauchen wir
gehen Technik ja ich weiß nicht ich bin
ja mehr so für Bio ne ja prima dann
nehmen wir Möglichkeit zwei wir fressen
nicht mehr jeden Tag Fleisch mit 30%
weniger Schweinefleischproduktion
könnten in Deutschland pro Jahr 5
Millionen Tonnen mehr Getreide angebaut
werden
ja dann nehme ich doch lieber die
Gentechnik genau
kann man nicht helfen
an
ZDF meldet gerade Toilettenpapier wird
knapp sofort nur
noch ach du scheiße jetzt geht's los ich
habe es euch gesagt am Ende wird sowieso
geplündert hey mein Nico damit kann sie
nicht den Arsch abwischen Carolin
Kebekus vielen Dank
nein ich mache hier gar nichts mehr
bevor ihr nicht den Kanal abonniert und
ein Like da lasst
ich habe die Schnauze voll
ja los lasst ein Abo da